ici des chambres de chs elle dit qu'ils
n'ont plus de résidents plus loin des
piles de chaises et de lits témoigne de
la tragédie qui a frappé ici à
l'institut universitaire de gériatrie de
montréal
la coved a tué 53 résidents ils avaient
plus envie de liez vous souhaite à la
pandémie et on a pris des décisions très
très rapides
la plus importante réaménager
complètement l'édifice donc fait grande
chambre à quatre patients a été
transformée en deux chambres
individuelles donc avec constallation de
cloisons créer des chambres
individuelles va diminuer de moitié le
nombre de résidents sur sept étages
lakovic force le réseau a rénové pour
limiter la propagation des chambres à
quatre on en avait puis si tu as tu une
chambre à quatre pianos un qui est
positif c'est sûr
presque que les trois autres vont l'être
le gériatre david lussier a lui même
attrapé l'aco vide au début de la
pandémie
il constate que cette lutte a marqué
plusieurs des employés des ch et celle
des frappes et un sentiment de
d'impuissance
puis je dirais aussi un sentiment de un
peu de culpabilité de ne pas avoir pu
trouver une façon d'éviter ça qu'est ce
que j'aurais pu faire autrement
l'établissement doit donc aider les
employés à prendre soin d'eux mêmes donc
le brasseur a indiqué que oui je suis là
pour vous une brigade a été créé pour
épauler les employés depuis le printemps
quatre mille interventions ont été
faites auprès du personnel la direction
pense que les travailleurs sont prêts à
affronter une deuxième vague
on appelle cela la croissance post
traumatique donc le fait d'aborder
quelques jours d'être difficile ces jo
sur le coup mais qu'elles sont
on réalise qu on a quelques kilomètres
au nord on retrouve robert tremblay au
ch et celle des notre-dame-de-la-merci
ici le quart des résidents ont été
emportés vingt-sept personnes dans son
montage de ces personnes qui sont
décédées des très très très très bonne
famille est très très très bons amis
aussi le deuil est donc particulièrement
difficile
tc la vie assez notre mémorial à
l'intérieur de notre dame de la merci
des dizaines de papillons sur un mur du
souvenir un pour chaque résident mort de
l'aco vide et ici comme dans plusieurs
ch et celle des touchés
la tragédie a fait naître un élan de
solidarité de s'apercevoir que seul on
peut rien mais quand on est ensemble
vers un même but on peut faire beaucoup
robert trambly pense donc que son ch et
celle des est prête à affronter la
deuxième vague a tenté semaine ils font
les données sur les personnes pillent je
pense que grid fait des milliers de
préposés formé cet été y arriveront dans
les ch et celle des en septembre et
partout les mesures d'hygiène ont été
resserrées on a tous les équipements de
protection qu'on a besoin on est en
mesure ou d'incapacité dépistage aussi
qu'on n'avait pas l'art du début de la
première vague dont on n'est pas du tout
à la même classe ici david gêne-t-il et
radio canada
mon frère